[Applause]
[Music]
how did you get kicked out of the Trump
rally but managed to look so fabulous
people were saying bye-bye Prince
bye-bye Prince and that is this shocking
to me okay one two volume okay for
anyone out there who's contemplating
going to a trump rally at some point
protesting what advice do you have
don't be afraid because I could have
been hit I could have been hit and that
fear was in me I needed to get what I
need to say no and if you could say
anything at all to mr. Donald Trump what
is your one message Donald Trump this is
not the last time you see me because I
will be going for presidency and you'll
see the space again